i've been asking everyone i've been
interviewing recently a few of the same
questions
to start off every interview so i'm
going to start uh
with you guys um what tv series would
you love to guest star on
wow um i haven't really been watching
like you know a bunch of tv lately
because of school and everything
but it'd be really cool to be like the
main star in a show have my own show
that would be amazing
that's my dream job because i get to go
to work every day
and you know i'm really creative so i
love to write
and i love to create a bunch of
different things so it would be amazing
if i could have my own show
and you know have a say in everything
that happens that'd be amazing
um a tv show for me
that's a hard question because i don't
watch a lot of tv i watch more movies
but um
there's a show um
maybe you know actually isn't that
um the boys with seth rogen isn't that
yeah probably that one definitely that
one i would say
that shows funny uh that show is
fantastic um
speaking of movies uh for both of you uh
what movie do you think you've seen the
most
for me i can't necessarily like watch
movies over and over and over again
except for some movies that are really
good then i'll sit down and watch them
over again
i've watched haunted mansion over and
over again
i've watched you know a lot of movies
plenty of times it's hard to think of
just one on the spot
i used to be obsessed with back to the
future at a young like really young
and uh i remember i was so obsessed i
would go up to people
when i was like in fifth grade and i'd
be like don't call me a chicken
they'd be like okay and i'd be like wait
call me a chicken so i can act out the
scene from back to the future you know
but i was obsessed with that movie i
love marty mcfly
he was awesome yes uh that movie is what
we call kind of good
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna agree with
you on that um
so jumping into why i get to talk to you
guys today um
what for for each of you when were you
actually allowed to see
coming to america i'm i'm just curious
because you're both
younger and the movie obviously is i
don't know 30 something years old i'm
just curious
when you guys got first got to see it um
i was probably around 10 or 11
when i first saw it yeah me um
i'm actually 12 right now so i saw not
too long ago i've seen it plenty of
times before i got this
audition and of course it was you know
the tv version so there was nothing
bad in it that i couldn't see and i
watched it with my mother of course
i completely understand uh i would
imagine that
making a movie of this size and scale
for both of you
was like obviously it's an amazing
experience but for people that are
watching this interview
that are not familiar with how movies
work what do you think would surprise
people about like the making of coming
to america
lots of people are going gonna have a
lot of fun seeing
all the little like easter eggs and like
hints towards the original movie that
you can see
and i think that's gonna um i think lots
of people will be surprised and
there'll be lots of little twists that
people aren't expecting
and uh yeah for me i think it would be
all the
huge people that are in the movie all
the big stars
i think that would be a great pleasant
surprise for all the people who see the
movie
obviously you guys weren't working every
single day while the movie was filming
but did you end up going to set on like
a particular day that you weren't
scheduled
because you wanted to watch somebody
actually filming something
see here's the thing about that i wanted
to do that
but i was still 17 so there was child
labor laws that
literally would not allow me to do that
even though
i like really wanted to i just couldn't
because it was against the law yeah i
couldn't do that either
but there was one point when there were
some people you know performing and
doing their thing on set and i got to
stay before i went home
to watch that because i i just couldn't
miss it it was
amazing to watch i think i know what
you're talking about
um for each of you again i would imagine
making this was just awesome
but when you think back on the shoot is
there like a day or two
that you will always remember forever
and like do you remember what it was
about that day
there was um the last day of filming i
remember me and
kylie when we were done with everything
craig
like put us on stage and he thanked us
in front of everyone
and it was just a really nice moment and
it was really it was really sweet and
kind
yeah and everybody was exchanging gifts
and saying goodbye
a lot of people were crying especially
me i was crying the whole ride home
i didn't i didn't want to go that's why
i love
filming and i love acting so much
because i realize just how much i want
to do it
um it was amazing uh i'm a big fan of
ruth carter who did the costumes in the
movie
i'm just curious for each of you what
was it like working with ruth
and hypothetically what did you borrow
from set because i know you wouldn't
have stolen anything
i loved all the costumes it was so much
fun walking into my trailer every day
and seeing a brand new
outfit or a brand new dress or a costume
it was so much fun to see that and all
the different accessories
she even had you know i could take in
the accessory that
the accessories that would go in the
hair and everything that we would wear
it was so much fun
trying on a bunch of different outfits
that was a lot of fun i couldn't even
choose a favorite because they were all
so cool you know like the fighting
outfits and
the ceremonial type things that we would
wear while we're sitting on their own
they were all amazing
yeah it was a joy to work with ruth
she's so great at her job and
um you know as an actor
costumes have such a big impact on how
you play your character
and really can help you you know
sink into your character very well so um
that she helped that i feel like that
helped a lot with me
finding out who oma was a little bit too
and um yeah it was just fun trying on
our
clothes and um yeah she was awesome
did you guys take home anything from set
i snatched a ponytail that i wasn't
supposed to pass though
i didn't steal it though they gave it to
me but um i don't
know if i was supposed to take they they
gave it to me
i got it they gave up you no no don't do
this
they gave it to me but they they told me
to keep it on the down
low but it's not really the down low
because i'm talking about it in an
interview but
they gave it to me okay
but yeah i got to keep um this ring that
i
always wear on set it's so pretty um
i got to keep it it was i was glad that
i got to keep it actually because i
enjoyed wearing it on set and i'd always
be staring at it during takes and i'd be
like
and i love how it looks so i asked to
keep in there like
all right dude they did the same with
bella they said
all right but just keep it on the down
low i mean not that you're not supposed
to but you know just
just just stay a little quiet about it i
completely get it hey listen congrats on
being part of the movie i wish you guys
nothing but the best
uh good luck with the rest of your
interviews thank you